yeah
it's all the lights on yeah
[Music]
[Music]
I'll look to the emergency first should
we be required to build you would you
please leave the building by the nearest
exit to the chamber our assembly point
will be in the public car park at the
side of the Civic suite vacua shouldn't
click any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that this meeting will be
audio required or recorded and can I ask
you to switch off your mobile phones or
put them to silence thank you my name is
Lorien Shaw and I'm chair today my other
colleagues are helpful Williams David
Mary and we have our councils legal
advisor can IRC people please
identifying themselves and if witnesses
are applicable please chairman my name's
Steve spero or a County license officer
for Essex Police and on my right is
called an Ashford is the licensing lead
for Essex Police the licensing manager
thank you very much please be aware if
you need to speak you need to turn we
can only have this mic on and I another
so so if you do need to speak the
council council's licensing officer
please good morning I'm Jennifer my
principal licensing obviously District
Council thank you
the premises license holder my name is
James Rankin and I'm representing kevin
horn who sits to my left and alan
simpson his man strandings list
[Music]
authorities
any interested parties any
representatives I've made any
representations now he did indicate it
in advance that they wish to address the
subcommittee it's recommended only one
person speak okay we are here for the
licensing application peeps toothbrush
section 53 ie each person will be
allowed 15 minutes permitted for the
premises holder to present their
submission 15 minutes permitted for a
reasonable responsible authority 15
minutes permitted for all interested
party submissions 15 minutes for the
applicants to present their case all
parties that make submissions at the
hearing will also be given two minutes
at the end of the hearing to make a
closing statement
the council's license officer will be
asked to introduce the application
please
okay the purpose for the report today is
it's determined an application for a
summary review of a premises license in
particular to consider what's that's
considered appropriate for the promotion
of the license and objectives to decide
if the entrance that's proposed cease to
have effects all together or if the
premises license should become subject
to any steps which the Licensing
Authority considers are appropriate
we're making its determination on the
review and to consider relevant
representations as a result of the
review application on the 7th of
February 2008 scene an application for a
summary review of a premises license
under section 53 a of the license in a
2003 it was received from Essex Police
and respect of a premises license issue
to the pink toothbrush 19 to 23 the High
Street Raley a copy of the application
certificate under section 53 8 of the
licensing Act and the police officers
statement were served on the premises
that license holder and all responsible
authorities the certificate stated in
the opinion of Superintendent Nick
Morris of Essex Police the premises were
associated with both serious crime and
disorder on the 8th of February in
accordance with section 53 B of the
licensing acts the licensing authority
after reading the Essex Police summary
review application determined within 48
hours a statutory time frame to
implement interim steps to take effect
immediately
the premises to which the application
relates is a nightclub situated on Raley
High Street teaming Limited has held the
premises license with rocks with
different district counts all since the
9th of August 2005 they previously held
the license with the Magistrates Court
and have been trading for 30 years Kevin
Horne has been the designated premises
supervisor since 2009 when determine the
summer review application the committee
must have regards the promotion of the
license and objectives which are
invention of crime and disorder Public
Safety prevention of public nuisance and
protection of children from harm all
parties involved have been served with
the relevant notices and documentation
required by paragraph 6 or 7 of the
license in acts 2003 hearing regulations
in 2005 the options today the following
options are available to members to
modify conditions to such extent as
members consider necessary for the
promotion of the licensing objectives
and any mandatory conditions that must
be included be to include from the scope
of the premises license any of the
license for activities to which the
application relates see to remove the
designated premises supervisor DITA to
suspend the premises licence for a
period of not exceeding three months
to revoke the premises license or leave
the premises license in its present
state recommendation is proposed that
the subcommittee resolves to determine
the application having considered all
representations made of the hearing the
premises license holders mission please
but before the police because it's the
police's application
yes sorry we're gonna clarify that sorry
yes we'll do it now do it Ronny kneel in
order to apologize I'm running older but
I'm just taking advice could we have the
policeman thank you madam chairman is
microphone on ok thank you madam
chairman um there have been serious
matters at this club which was
determined by the interim steps of a
summary review since then
Essex place have been negotiating with
the premises licence holder on various
conditions which we've agreed with them
and you received a copy
prior to this hearing I don't intend to
go through every one of these conditions
you would have read them yourselves and
I'm very grateful to the premises
license in order to who's been very
cooperative in regard to adding these
new conditions to promote the licensing
objectives so it's clearly a matter for
you on how much detail you further wish
me to add so that but to speed the
hearing up somewhat
these are agreed conditions and Essex
Police are satisfied at this moment in
time
do you have any questions regarding the
conditions I noticed that in a couple of
the conditions items are to be produced
to the police or and/or Licensing
Authority staff upon reasonable request
on just a little bit worried about the
word reasonable which is a subjective
word and I'm just concerned whether
that's might
you go turn it off David okay if I could
answer that question then counselor
um it's through the fire protection act
in that we can't like all assuming
request that we have to show that that
request is raised one of the time
protection acts are used to provide some
degree of protection to the license
holder I've also got a question
on paragraph nine
the first sentence requires that any
seized items should be deposited in it
being the safe or cabinet then goes on
in the last sentence I pick upon in the
penultimate sentence to provide that
only the police will have access keys so
that's going to prevent the items being
deposited in the safe if I my assist
it's a standard condition assist which
tends to ask premises to use and there
was a manufactured drug safe that allows
the envelope or deal happens to be
placed into and there is a double
locking system where only Essex Police
have the key so it prevents obviously
Dorst off me or else obtaining the drugs
but someone can put them in thank you
and if you could dim on the special
conditions on on for and could we how I
did Halloween and any special occasions
on item for of the conditions we would
like to add Halloween and any special
occasions
sorry so it's a matter for the committee
to determine if that's required and it
matter for the premises license I wanted
to comment on that I'll be perfectly
happy with those dates at it in just in
response to that last question for Mike
and we really put that on because such
days when their hours are extended
Halloween doesn't tend to have their as
extended so that was wrong we'd asked no
none this they asked for a temporary
event notice [ __ ] is a matter inside
of yourselves if you wish to place them
but we didn't ask that it's that
particular purpose just picking up on
that last point I suppose that we could
word the condition in this way that on
occasions when a temporary events notice
has been applied for and granted and the
hours have been extended
does that make sense rather than
actually identifying Halloween or or any
other occasion
excellent my job is made easier by the
fact that I know that two of your
numbers sat on the original application
for summary review and I also know that
all of you have read the papers and so
you will know the background and there
are just two or three matters of
importance it's a matter of detail that
mr. horn wishes to correct because he
wouldn't want this committed to leave
with the impression that this is
somebody that had received warnings from
the police and had ignored those
warnings and he wouldn't want you to
leave with the impression that this is a
set of premises the
has a stash of offensive weapons ready
and to hand and did just by web
background these premises have been
operated by mr. horn for over 35 years
now and under the old act the 1964 act
and under the new act the 2003 act as in
force from 2005 there has never been any
application to revoke under the old
legislation or any application to review
under the new legislation and this is a
a rare creature in that this is a set of
premises which has stayed
privately-owned for all that period his
staff have been there for years his
barmaid has been there for 33 years
Tony Lord who's the manager has been
there for 28 years the disc jockey has
been there for 24 years and it's a
matter of some pride that mr. Horne has
in these premises that he's always
worked well with the local licensing
officer he was instrumental in starting
the pub watch for example in town and
he's been a member was a board member of
bida for 17 years is a tireless
fundraiser for charities locally and
nationally and so has taken this very
seriously indeed he always as I say has
enjoyed a good relationship with the
police and in the papers on first glance
you may have gained the impression that
the police wagged their finger at mr.
horn on the 8th of November and told him
that they were unhappy with the state of
this doorstop
now it's unnecessary for me to lock
horns with the police but suffice to say
that you will have seen at page five
point one Tony Lord statement he was the
person that was present at the meeting
which these gentlemen were not present
at and has a clear recollection and that
whilst CCTV was sought in relation to an
instant which had happened the previous
weekend and whilst discussion
were had about the officers son who's in
Brixton and parking difficulties in
Brixton nothing was said along the lines
of we are extremely unhappy with your
door staff and we will be challenging or
premises to a review unless you address
that so I just wanted to deal with that
point first then I wanted to deal with
the instant of the 18th of November
because there is language that's used
which I'm afraid is not supported by the
evidence the CCTV the most obvious one
is when there's an analysis of the CCTV
minute by minute
it has mr. horn as a gentleman that is
seizing one of these weapons which are
described as metal poles and the like he
was at Legoland on the night in question
and lest you come away with the
impression that these were a stash of
offensive weapons it was a mop and a
broom handle which he kept behind the
hatch for cleaning purposes and remember
to the context in which these were
deployed in a defensive posture by the
doorman the two doormen with the bur out
on the door that the protagonist had a
fireman's axe which was four foot long
so I wouldn't want you to get the wrong
impression and again similarly the
offense all the events relating to the
27th of January you remember when a
gentleman was forcibly ejected from the
premises through the rear fire door
again a close analysis of the CCTV and
we didn't do it suffice to say I've seen
it and the police have had an
opportunity since the application for
review has been submitted to look at it
again and but suggestions that the
person that was being
it was repeatedly punched in the face
and kicked on the floor is not supported
by the evidence and it's perfectly clear
on an analysis of the CCTV that the
gentleman who was ejected girlfriend was
unhappy with his behavior and by the
same token that of his male companion
and that's really all that I was going
to say because I didn't want you to come
away as I say with the wrong impression
so what we have been extremely grateful
for the assistance offered by mr.
Sparrow we were due to have a meeting on
site on Friday but the snows and the ice
put paid to that so we've been unable to
actually finalize the positioning of the
CCTV cameras and that's something that
could be done very quickly we've already
rotated them into positions which are
far better for the purposes of
surveillance we are ready to go with the
body camera which is a suggestion
helpfully made by mr. Sparrow and we're
ready to go with additional cameras if
it's thought by mr. spera that those are
needed as I say we were unable to meet
on Friday and what we built into these
conditions you will see is a 28-day lead
in lead in period four conditions three
four and five and that there are it's
been mentioned by your blended legal
adviser that there are many other
conditions which pertain to this license
that need looking at and tinkering with
because many of them are ancient and
outdated and duplicated by other
legislation and it seems to me to be an
ideal opportunity to review the whole of
the license and excise those conditions
which quite frankly needn't be on there
shouldn't have been on there are
redundant and we can do that
I hope in the absence of the committee
after you've made your decision and we
all of us here can get our heads
together and decide what is the
appropriate forum but just as a general
pointer mr. Sparrow has had helpfully
said that he would have had no
difficulty with mandatory conditions
remaining and everything else coming off
and then these new conditions going on
as well and that seems to me to be an
eminently sensible course so there we
have it I've got mr. horn with me who
can answer any questions that you may
have I've got mr. Lord
who's with me as well but you'll seen
his statement
it's a page five point one and unless
I've entirely misread the circumstances
I was rather hoping to leave it there
have you rescheduled the meeting for
fraud from Friday we spoken today and
it's due to be next week isn't it do you
have any plans on introducing the
challenge 25 which I understand is if
anybody looks under the age of 25 you
have to ask for identification
yes you do
it's fine thank you and and you
anticipated be quite happy continuing
with third party door stuff
employ doorman who were employed by the
club itself
[Music]
well
and it makes sense and we understand the
reason
and agency
do you have the same girl stuff on every
week or do they they change because of
different shift patterns
since these conditions were instigated
have you had any
[Music]
excellent that's it thank you thank you
very much thank you closest point
reserved rights make our DC two minutes
no I would say is it makes sense to
review these conditions and take off the
old conditions because otherwise they're
going to conflict with these agreed
conditions we've got to die so we do
need to go through the license after
thank you very briefly we are satisfied
that these agree conditions will allow
our fears and protector customers at the
department we're grateful for the degree
of engagement that mr. horner shone with
us we're confident with these conditions
the premises will continue to be well
run and not cause us a problem now I can
confirm the previous tips that have just
been mentioned we've got notice inspect
the door start from that night and I
armor is a security company were used to
dealing you can Essex and not had any
concerns about thank you very much
I'm gonna turn this now we'll go
upstairs to my collaboration um you're
welcome to stay and hopefully it won't
be too long thank you and that is will
drove there if you need it I'm afraid
thank you
I read them handwritten newspaper so
please bear with me it's not in my
handwriting so time it is the
committee's decision that in order to
promote the license license objective of
the prevention of crimes and disorder
the conditions submitted are agreed are
to be imposed as a risk as written some
save for condition for amended number
for at least five si a licensed or
supervisor shall be on duty at the
premises while licensable activities are
taking place and for at least 30 minutes
after premises have closed on a Saturday
bank holiday Sunday's Christmas Eve New
Year's Eve and on any event where a
temporary event notice is applied for
and granted or hours extended there
should be at least six such door
supervisors deployed for the same time
periods all door supervisors excuse me
engage all door supervisors engaged
outside the main entrance to the
premises or supervising or controlling
queues shall wear high visibility
jackets or vests the interim in interim
steps premises to suspend to be
suspended until each and every door
supervised so door supervisors are
employed by the premises a undertake a
refresher course in physical
intervention skills provided by a
trainer who themselves have been trained
by a by a si a endorsed awarding
organization and have si a required
qualification for training B to have
received such training in the last
twelve months and to suspend the license
immediately until a the completion of
the training of existing staff or the
deployment of it
alternative si a triangle agency staff
to satisfaction of Licensing Authority
these steps are to remain in place for
28 days the conditions are to be
implemented within 28 days of this
adjudication further conditions of the
licensing of the license are to be
amending in agreement between the
responsible officers of the license and
authority the premises holder and the
police thank you you will get a copy of
this in in full in writing thank you
you would our request can revisit the
question of the interim steps which has
to be done at this stage and you can
then withdraw the interim steps that
were imposed on the 8th of February and
I'm inviting you to do there
yes I understand
so right it's an odd way of wording it I
have to say it might be a more elegant
way just simply to remove the interim
steps and impose the requirement that
these conditions must be complied with
within 28 days yes that I'm instructed
that these are already in place and I'm
just concerned that the interim step its
conditioned in the way that it is I
think it's good to get a good cause
operation there difficulties for those
that have to comply
the entry whilst we confirm they will
stay in place for the 21 days as stated
by our officer no it it was worded in
that way that whereby there would have
been a suspension had staff agency staff
not being put in place a suspension will
only apply if there are no agency staff
covering the door or any employed staff
currently who have received the training
it wasn't that the license was going to
be suspended unless it was the case that
that sufficient staff could not be put
in place and I think the committee would
like that to remain in place certainly
for the period of time up to when these
conditions can be formally imposed by
the licensing authority but no there's
no certainly no intention that the
license be suspended as long as those
staff are in place then the license
continues
[Music]